Hi, I'm Jack Lowden.
And I'm Olivia Cook.
And in our new series,
"Slow Horses,"
we take you deep into
the world of British Espionage.
It's not as slick, or as glamorous
as you might think,
but it does have
a language of its own.
And we are going to test our skills
in deciphering that code.
Are you ready?
Because I'm ready.
I am not ready.
Bang And Burn.
Is it when you quickly
digest evidence
and then burn it
so no one sees it?
Chat them up,
sleep with them
and then
get outta there.
- Demolition and sabatoge operations.
- Oh, of course.
You're kidding, right?
Unbelievable.
A man that makes shoes.
Shoe cobbler.
Cobbling evidence together?
- A tailer.
-A tailor?
Someone who tails,
and not a tailor of clothes.
A spy who creates false passports.
Naked.
No alias.
Having no alias.
Is the target naked?
Is the target in clear view?
Is it an agent
that looks good?
Particularly, looks good naked.
A spy without operating...
That's probably the closest
we've gotten.
Next time.
A Bird Watcher.
A spy on the lookout,
whose..
-Someone high up.
-Yeah.
Surveillance.
Someone that works
specifically in surveillance.
Slang used by British Intelligence
for a spy.
Terrible.
Yeah, nailed that.
Boy, you people are slow.
To find out more about spy words,
and the people
crazy enough to do it,
watch "Slow Horses,"
coming soon to Apple TV+.